all right another wrap is episode 5 of
obi-wan kenobi otherwise known as
episode 5 of me making jokes well this
fourth video anyway because episode one
and two were in one video you know what
i mean new ob one episode means
guaranteed video of me joking about some
of the ridiculous [ __ ] in that episode
that's how i see it anyway it's kind of
what my week is revolving around right
now all right so spoilers for the
obi-wan kenobi series leading up through
episode five and talk about the spoilers
in episode five that said where we left
off is riva left a little tracker on
leia's little pet droid but apparently
it's more than a tracker it's like a
thing that reprograms the droid to have
red eyes and be evil so that's kind of
where we are now they all go to this
planet and reeve attracts them there
it's like all right lord vader i'm gonna
go down i'm gonna confront them and
vader goes down and to confront obi-wan
and anyhow though the episode does start
out with an obi-wan anakin skywalker
flashback from before attack of the
clones anakin skywalker has his padawan
hair doesn't have his metal hand which
means it's before attack of the clones
which also means it it's scene that
really does show
the budget of the show being a tv show
budget because with mandalorian you
could have fooled me anyone shows me a
scene from mandalorian it'd be like
that's a star wars movie they'd be like
nope it's actually a show it was really
cool seeing a movie budget in a tv show
and disney plus was like hey we're gonna
have movie budgets on our shows how cool
is that pretty cool while you kept it
going it's like when you got to one of
the most beloved star wars characters of
all time getting his own show it's like
not tv show budget now and i say that
because it was cool seeing hayden
christensen and ewan mcgregor on screen
together and you can tell that like
that's what they were talking about like
hayden chris didn't even mcgregor in the
interviews they were like it was so cool
being on screen together again this was
no doubt the scene they were talking
about and it's cool to see them
have that fun though it does go to show
you that the relationship that actors
have with the content is much different
than the relationship fans have with the
content because when i was watching it i
was like that is cool you're finally
using hayden in episode five that said
that the aging stuff that the marvel
movies had you could go for doing that i
don't want to get too reliant on the
aging but seeing a 40 year old hayden
christensen play a 19 year old that did
i know i just couldn't take my eyes off
it it kind of made me chuckle so on this
planet all the good guys are behind this
huge steel door and then riva and a
bunch of stormtroopers go down there and
reeva and obi-wan actually have they
talk through this big steel door with
force with the aid of the force that's
where obi wan's like yo hunting veda
which
leads to a
right i guess that pause is all i need
to say like i have so many questions
about that all right so i it addresses
that she saw anakin skywalker in the
temple when she was a padawan figured
that was the case anakin kills her
friends or vader kills her friends vader
before he was a cyborg and then stabs
her and was like
i'm sure she's dead
let's move on i'll circle around to that
in a second but the point is obi-wan was
like you need my help to take him down
you can't do this alone she's like you
have no idea what i've done alone
everyone should have been like
i'm not killed vader
there is that in the course of 10 years
i feel like she should have had the
opportunity the last couple episodes
i've seen opportunities for her to kill
vader she wouldn't have made it out of
the room alive other people would have
killed her but the opportunity was there
i feel like it's someone in her position
she has to weigh it you know she has to
be like okay what are the odds that beat
vader in a fight zero all right so
apparently i just have to backstab him
when i have the opportunity she did it
wrong in this episode she does try to do
that what do you think is gonna happen
man why not just light the lightsaber
where the ignition of the lightsaber
goes through them i mean the last jedi
all right i'm kind of speeding up i
skipped over a lot of stuff and i'm
about to use the last jedi as an example
here we go but in the last jedi when
kylo ren killed snoke at least he made
it where the ignition killed snoke
lighting a lightsaber and then trying to
slash someone that's just like just so
much time for them to stop you and vader
stops her all right before we get to
that though man i'm bouncing all around
here i had coffee that's why we're gonna
go back to them running through the
tunnel and because the doors open and
storm troopers are shooting at them
storm troopers are the worst shots
they've ever been which you could
canonically say yeah they're terrible
shots and obi-wan and and they get
better as the star wars movies like buy
a new hope they're actually better shots
i mean it sounds impossible but that's
the situation because man this was a
narrow hallway and there were a lot of
stormtroopers there were fewer good guys
stormtroopers just yeah good guys could
have just stood the ground and shot and
a bunch of stormtroopers would have
fallen but all the good guys would have
fallen i played enough first person
shooters i know how that is that was a
very narrow hallway people die in narrow
hallways even obi-wan stopped to help
someone like oh come on they're all good
wow they really do suck don't they
almost like they suck enough for someone
to slap a helmet and that would take
them down so just getting to it you know
vader lands and then rebus like all
right i got him in the back go get him
and then vader's look tromping down the
hallway this is actually they did a
better job at vader in here
giving that entrance of him being
powerful i guess is what i'm trying to
say but i gotta say vader in this series
has not had a moment like he had in jedi
fallen order you know i mean that was
pure big dick energy right there he
hasn't had that yet you know when jedi
fallen order takes place before the
obi-wan series so it's kind of funny
that he had that and then just now he
doesn't anyhow he grabs a ship with the
force which i was like okay this is a
good display of how hardcore and
powerful vader is kind of reminded me of
the force unleashed you know but you do
see the cgi in the ship the fact that
the ship looked so just cgi when it
stopped in cgi when it fell and there
was another ship behind that ship that
then took off and vader was like you
know what grabbing ships out of the air
was so seven seconds ago like he just
didn't grab it why didn't he grab it
don't give me that [ __ ] like oh he was
wiped out with the force it took all he
had to bring that ship down he didn't
look like he did he was just kind of
watching it fly away he might as well
have just waved you can emote that you
know you can have him kind of hunch over
and look at it like have him look wiped
out if he's wiped out no he just watches
the ship go away that obviously has
obi-wan on it and then riva comes up
behind vader like i said earlier and
just strikes the lightsaber and tries to
slash him and then he stops her and i
did also like that it wasn't really a
fight because i was like dude if riva
fights vader and puts up a fight it's
like oh will she win i'm gonna call
straight up [ __ ] this kind of vader
looked like darkseid and injustice too
you know just like he looked like he
didn't have to try he looked like
anthony hopkins and the mask of zorro
when antonio banderas was fighting him
but antonio banderas was drunk and he
just had no shot at winning i like that
i like the fact that it wasn't a fight
it was vader toying until vader got
bored and then vader was like okay stab
and then the grand inquisitor is alive
because she got promoted to grand
inquisitor and that's when i was like
okay well you're probably going down in
this episode the grand inquisitor walks
in he lived through the stabbing riva
lived through the stabbing when she was
a kid and now she's living through the
stabbing now that she's an adult the
only person in the galaxy who's not
gonna live through a lightsaber stabbing
is apparently qui-gon jinn but vader was
like you think i don't remember padawan
insinuating that he remembers her when
she was a kid
and i have a lot of questions there i
can't find any reason that vader would
remember this girl when he was killing
younglings which implies that he knew
that she knew that he was anakin
skywalker that anakin skywalker and
vader were the same person which right
there i don't understand how she knew
anakin skywalker and vader were the same
person if a stormtrooper called him lord
vader that'd be one thing but all she
knew was that anakin skywalker killed
her friends and then there was this guy
who was a cyborg who looks nothing like
anakin skywalker has a completely
different name he's called darth vader
and somehow she's like oh it's obviously
the same person there are not multiple
murderous [ __ ] with lightsabers in
this galaxy they obviously are the same
so though she saw anakin skywalker kill
her friends i don't know how she pieced
together that this super death cyborg
known as darth vader was the same person
and i don't know why darth vader
apparently knew that she knew that and
just let her live this whole time i
don't know why he wouldn't have just
been like wait you know my secret
inquisitors are kind of a dime a dozen
at this point there are a lot of them
i'll just find another to be fair it
doesn't say that vader knew that she
knew that anakin and vader were the same
person i suppose i'm making that
connection because i assume in a world
where people with the force can read the
minds and thoughts of other people vader
would have done that and he would have
seen that and he would know that she
knew that or vader's just an idiot this
show's actually turned a lot of people
into idiots i mean now bale organ is an
idiot why because he calls obi-wan
kenobi on his little hologram and he
gives verbal evidence of the kids that
oh he can't find out about the kids and
the one on tattooing why would bail
organa leave that kind of evidence on
obi-wan kenobi's answering machine even
jesse pinkman in breaking bad was more
careful when it came to the answering
machine also why would obi-wan kenobi
give that recording device with that
evidence on it to rando wannabe jedi i
mean the most important thing to obi-wan
kenobi i feel in this phase in this life
is preserving the identity of anakin's
children and keeping that secret from
the empire so the one day luke can be
trained the galaxy can be restored
literally the galaxy is counting on this
secret and obi-wan was like i don't know
you that well but hold on to this for me
the information on there is
arguably the most important information
in the galaxy that's like i just did my
yearly breaking bad binge there's
another breaking bad comparison coming
at you here that's like walter white
having the lotto ticket coordinates you
know that's everything that he holds
dear it's the culmination of all of his
work is where that gps goes to that's
like him giving it to badger skinny pete
being like hold on to that for me also
did baylor gannon know that anakin
skywalker was darth vader because he
says in that answering machine recording
that he sent obi-wan he says oh
something about he can't find out about
the kids so it's like everyone knew
anakin was vader except obi-wan the
funny thing is when obi-wan's talking to
riva and he's like you can't beat him
alone or he's going to concentrate on me
and then i'll help you defeat him he now
knew riva's motivation
he could safely assume when vader comes
to the planet reeva is gonna make her
move and obi-wan instead of facing vader
or helping riva was like
that will [ __ ] her piece he just gets on
the ship and leaves so she didn't die he
had to have thought he was leaving her
to her death i was like damn dude 10
years in the deserts made you cold
that's also another piece of [ __ ]
like why didn't vader kill her why
didn't vader kill her in the previous
episode when he force choked her i feel
like he would have just snapped her neck
then in this episode when she actually
tries to kill him he just what leaves
her there can at least learn from the
past and be like she lived through this
before hold on
now i'm good he doesn't do that just
kind of leaves her there it's like i'm
sure she'll die from it this time then
she gets the answering machine recording
that bail organa stupidly sent to
obi-wan kenobi like for me being a star
wars fan watching the obi-wan series i
can imagine that it's
it must be something close to how
democrats are or like democrats watching
the biden president say well it's like i
mean you knew the mess that it was going
to be but deep down you were hoping for
something better and then it's happening
you're like
those are my fears that i had
so you're not surprised but you are
disappointed you have two options at
that point you can cnn and be like
nothing to see here everything's perfect
or you can just make jokes at how
[ __ ] ridiculous it all just is all
right so obi-wan kenobi episode five
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you